The Big Bang was probably a pretty violent
event.
So how did the Universe survive?
Hey guys, Amy here with DNews.
Most of us probably don’t lose too much
sleep wondering how the Universe survived
the Big Bang.
But scientists do, because by some accounts
it shouldn’t have.
It comes down to the Higgs particle.
The Higgs is part of a larger set of theories,
called the Standard Model of Physics.
The Standard Model is a theory that explains
how the basic building blocks of matter interact.
In short: Our entire universe is made of 12
different matter particles — six quarks
made of protons and neutrons and six leptons
that include electrons and electron neutrinos
— and four forces: and the gravitational,
electromagnetic, strong and weak nuclear forces.
We don’t know exactly what’s responsible
for the force of gravity, but the other three
forces result from the exchange of force-carrier
particles called bosons; particles of matter
transfer energy bewteen them by exchanging
these bosons, and each fundamental force has
its own corresponding boson.
The Higgs boson is responsible for giving
all particles mass and was discovered in 2012
with great fanfare -- you can find out more
on DiscoveryNews.com.
It’s the production of this Higgs particle
that’s problematic for the Big Bang Theory.
Some studies suggest that the production of
Higgs bosons during the initial accelerating
expansion immediately after the Big Bang should
have led to instability and its ultimate collapse!
Scientists have gone so far as to consider
developing a new physics to explain the origins
of the universe.
And the simple answer to solve the problem
might be gravity.
More specifically, the interaction between
gravity and those Higgs bosons.
Rather than speeding the collapse of the universe
just after the Big Bang, the interaction between
gravity and the Higgs particles, even if it
was a small one, would have been enough to
stabilize the universe against collapse!
And what’s more, this idea fits within the
Standard Model.
No new physics required!
Yay!
Of course, all that being said, there are
still scientists who are unsure that we've
even FOUND the Higgs boson, and still others
who question the cause of gravity or the Big
Bang at ALL.
Which is why we gotta keep searching for the
answers.
It's exciting, but it's like watching a very
slow moving sporting event.
Like, even slower than cricket.
What weird questions about the Big Bang keep
you guys up at night?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of
the week.